le plan diplomatique à présent bruno la
russie ce matin s'est dit prête à
reprendre les pourparlers ce qu'on peut
en attendre quelque chose oui alors ça
c'est de la communication puisque cette
gare est évidemment aussi une guerre de
communication c'est côté russe on dit
que une délégation à la frontière cette
fois ci contre la pologne et la
biélorussie est sur place on ne sait pas
exactement où pour l'instant est prête à
reprendre un second round de pourparlers
il y en a eu lundi déjà mais on ne
confirme pas par contre côté ukrainien
donc on va voir dans les prochaines
heures si ces négociations ont lieu
elles auront peut-être lieu mais le
problème sera sans doute le même que
celui qui était posée dès lundi c'est à
dire que les termes de la négociation ne
sont pas les mêmes pour les ukrainiens
pour les russes pour les russes en fait
il s'agit de négocier en position de
force de supériorité militaire en ayant
déclenché donc cette offensive censé
créer un peu le le chaos et l'effroi
chez les ukrainiens et donc d'exiger de
la part de l'ukraine une forme de
reddition et déjà une démilitarisation
bon le sort du régime politique du
président zine ce qui n'est pas réglée
encore mais peut-être aussi que ça fait
partie des demandes russe et côté
ukrainien on demande tout d'abord le
lard et de l'invasion russe avant de
commencer des discussions sérieuses on
sait qu'il ya quelques jours le
président hélène ce qui s'était déclaré
prêt à une certaine forme de neutralité
de l'ukraine déjà pour l'ukraine c'est
un grand pas ça veut dire que defacto
elle renoncerait à présenter sa
candidature à l'otan parler de rêve de
rejoindre le temps une semaine avant
absolument mais évidemment les
événements étant ce qu'ils sont il faut
un moment aussi dans une négociation
savoir lâcher un peu sur certains sujets
on a façon on n'en sortira pas tant
qu'il y aura pas un compromis c'est à
dire que chacun des deux camps lâche si
vous passez l'expression quelque chose
côté russe ça a pas l'air d'être
vraiment là
vision de ces négociations donc on voit
bien que pour l'instant les russes
malgré tout veulent montrer que certes
il mène l'offensive certes c'est très
dur ce qu'ils infligent à l'ukraine y
communique beaucoup aussi sur le fait
que sont frappés très durement
économiquement mais il insiste aussi en
terme de communication sur le fait
qu'ils veulent continuer à faire des
pourparlers avec l'ukraine seulement
c'est un peu de la négociation comme
souvent avec vladimir poutine
avec le fait que les conditions russes
ne sont pas vraiment négociable donc
évidemment il est compliqué d'avancer
merci beaucoup bruno pour votre
décryptage semi dieu on